[Music]
you've seen it with the thighs you've
seen it without the bus with just the
fast and with twos where the bus should
be now prepared for the latest mix of F
words and numbers in Furious 7 that's so
boring can we use the Japanese title
wild speed sky mission way better after
six fast and furious 'as you thought
they were done because they more or less
kept saying they were done into the road
one last job I thought that was our last
job old life is done how long have we
been doing
we getting paid rent but now they're
back for one last ride again after this
we're done one last ride which is at the
bare minimum there next to last ride but
after that ride
they've got to be done riding right I
mean where are they gonna go next space
tank then the plane now we got a
spaceship I would totally watch that
what began as Point Break with cars has
been spun off rebooted turned into a
heist film and jacked up on steroids now
they're really stretching to find new
things to jump a car out of in a
franchise that's completely ditched in
street racing routes but still remains
as committed as ever to booty
are you guys for real right now an
assassin is hunting down our heroes one
by one now Dom's crew must find a hacker
who can help them find a thing all that
trouble for this little thing that can
help them find the assassin you get
Ramsey you get the gods eye you get Shaw
who's hunting them down anyway making
you wonder why they bother since he
literally shows up everywhere they go
experience some of the most over-the-top
set pieces of the year like this awesome
car skydiving sequence then it raises
the bar with this incredible skyscraper
jump scene then watch their budget run
out before the finale which is basically
a generic car chase while two guerrillas
hit each other with sticks in a parking
lot
so hit the streets once again with
dominic toretto master of the dramatic
over the shoulder turn around who's so
Italian he wore a tank top to his own
wedding he's the man with the plan even
if the plan is incredibly stupid like
driving headfirst into a car driving
headfirst off a cliff
driving headfirst into a car again or
driving headfirst off a parking garage
you'll begin to wonder if it was
repeated head trauma that gave him his
trademark mumble growl so experience the
latest in a franchise so dumb its
chronological order is 1 2 4 5 6 3 7
full of dumb moments like this that is
kind of work
and this thing about street fights the
street always ones that had you really
worried about how they'd handle the
death of Paul Walker yet against odds
made a tasteful heartfelt and
emotionally powerful goodbye Wow
I honestly never expected a fast and
furious movie to make me cry
that was really well done so this is an
awkward transition but who's ready for
some car puns starring Michelle
Rodriguez Honda Rossi tire grease Gibson
Luda cruise race and Statham Jordana
Brewster Lucas black top drive on honk
sue curb Russell Lane the rock Johnson
and Vin Diesel that's just his name
that's not a pun car wars episode 7 we
couldn't decide which ending we liked
better for this trailer so here are all
three remember in the trailer when the
rock beat up Statham flexed out of a
cast and shot that drone because that's
everything he does in the movie come on
you've got the rock use him for crying
out loud
it's really nice out racially diverse
this movie is without calling a bunch of
attention to itself race was we invented
it up never mind
see you and me with some different
wallets hey you stole that from Hootie
and the Blowfish
[Music]
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies tell us your
choice for best honest Furious 7 ending
in the comments below
speaking of choices why don't you choose
to click the box to the left which will
take you to my epic voice channel full
of fun stuff like this little video with
Captain Obvious go ahead I'll read some
of your comments while I wait
I can't spheal nudist beach gentleman
from this day forward he will all refer
to me by the name Betty I'm an albatross
I'm an albatross on flap flap flap in my
albatross wings I don't know what were
yelling about